dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir where we expand
our knowledge in science and research
blackboard style lecture videos are
really popular on YouTube nowadays can
Academy is an excellent example of debt
where you get the feeling that someone
is sitting next to you and teaching you
not like someone who is addressing you
formally from the podium without
question these kinds of videos can
augment textbooks quite well however
they are often not easily searchable
this piece of work tries to take this
one step beyond the input is a video and
a transcript and the output of the
algorithm is an interactive lecture note
where you can not only see the most
important points during the lecture but
you can also click on some of them to
see full derivations of the expressions
let's outline the features that one
would like to see in a useable outlining
product it has to be able to find
milestones that are at the end of each
derivation to present them to the user
if you studied mathematics
you know how mathematical derivations go
following the train of thought of the
teacher is not always trivial it's also
important to find meaningful groupings
for a derivation this involves finding
similarities between drawings trying to
find out the individual steps and doing
a segmentation to get a series of images
out of it and finally the technique has
to be good at interleaving drawings and
formulae with written text in an
appealing and digestible way it is very
easy to mess up with this step as the
text has to describe the visuals even
though I wish tools like this existed
when I was an undergrad student it is
still important to just study study and
study and expand one's knowledge if
textbooks like this start to appear I'll
be the first in line and I'll not be
reading I'll be devouring them also
think about how smart the next
generation will be with awesome studying
materials like these thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time